انفجار غاز ضخم أدى إلى مقتل ما
لا يقل عن ثلاثة أشخاص وإصابة ما
يصل إلى 280
آخرين، ترى فقط تلك السحابة الهائلة
من النار، وهذا الفيديو يلتقط
اللحظة التي سيطرت فيها الكرة النارية على
سماء الليل، ويقول المسؤولون إن شاحنة
تحمل غازًا انفجرت أثناء الطهي
حدث هذا في محطة الغاز حوالي الساعة 11:00 مساءً.
يقول المسؤولون بالتوقيت المحلي إن الحريق أحرق
مستودعًا ثم احترق في
المنازل السكنية حيث كان الناس
لا يزالون بالداخل. تعمل أطقم العمل حتى
الصباح لإخماد هذا الحريق.
لا يوجد حتى الآن أي معلومات عن سبب
انفجار الشاحنة بالضبط، يمكنك رؤية
آثار ذلك هنا بالرغم من ذلك  فقط
البقايا المتفحمة بعد ذلك يقول الصليب الأحمر في كينيون إنه
تم إجلاء ما يقرب من 300 شخص إلى
المستشفيات حول نيروبي